welcome to our online exclusive roast
battle we're here with our judges
Nikki Glaser Anthony Jeselnik and a
roastmaster General Jeffrey Ross first
roaster of LA's finest fighters she's
beating some of the best battlers on the
west coast she's the beauty who's a
beast from Huntington Beach please
welcome Nicole Buckhannon
[Applause]
our opponent is also from Huntington
Beach and is in La Rose battle veteran
his jokes are as cerebral as his palsy
make it loud for the Celtic cripple is
Joey around
[Applause]
[Music]
we've got crap purses blood once a month
Wow like in this one great to see both
of you Joe that was an impressive
entrance you managed to turn your
colostomy bag into a musical instrument
Nicole how do you feel I feel good yeah
let's do this all right
yeah Joe how do you feel liver dollars
who wants to go first oh no that's my
maze a gentleman oh right
[Applause]
the cow wanted to go to law school but
he settled for having a bass that looks
like it was hit with the bar jo I don't
get it if you don't think I'm hot why
are you drooling
[Music]
[Applause]
six but Joe's a three like literally his
body a shape like the number three
breathe the amount of times you break
down crying every day the Cossacks are
actually very beautiful she could be an
actress and a porno parody of store
towards
thank you I think you at the face of an
actor in the body of his really bad
stunt double
[Applause]
that's a good body double Duke but you
look like you look like you know about
double bodies you know Nicole's lost her
virginity to a junkie
see what's only gonna let him get the
third but he didn't count on them you
see in a freebase the subtitle guy just
killed himself
[Applause]
you know Joe has a lot of criminals in
his family his a brother got six years
in prison but Joe is the only one who
got the chair
[Applause]
the goal is only jealous because even
with the wheelchair I still weigh less
than cenotes actually the goal the goal
does it where our most enjoyed sleeves
but see don't swear her depressing our
wrists
[Applause]
my life is very hard you wouldn't
understand Joe Joe you're doing stand-up
all wrong you're supposed to stay on
your stool not in your stool the go I
didn't sit my pants that's its you
smelling your twat I got it say the goal
looks like the type of girl doubts for
the manager tips because he's lonely I'm
single Anthony
I figured
[Applause]
I'm sure it's driving lovely maybe I
should throw Joe a pity I've always
wanted to know what it would be like to
have two Baca gargle sweet nothings in
my ear
that was something else
Nicole you had fantastic jokes you had a
fantastic demeanor you clearly enjoyed
yourself
I loved what you did up there Joe didn't
understand a word
I'm gonna go with Nicole on this one I
just I you made me so happy to watch
you're both both had such good jokes
this Joe the storage wars joke was like
so dead-on she definitely looks like
that no we're gonna call obviously
you're cute as I I love everything
about you and yours were so good the
subtitle joke oh my god that is the joke
where I go she has won this for me and
you made me proud to be a female
comedian today Nicole for the win you
know what Joe I love watching you your
delivery is slower than Domino's at 4
a.m. you always deliver bro the law
school bar joke was so funny give it up
for Joe
for me you were so natural it seems like
you've been insulting to disabled your
whole life I really enjoyed your
televised cry for help congratulations
[Applause]